tonight we're going to take a request
from somebody named malar axe who said
Sicilian defense shaven engine variation
please so we're slowly covering all of
the Sicilians one by one and today we'll
go ahead and throw it on the board and
then we'll start talking about it right
away so the shape and engine is after E
for c5 white plays an open Sicilian so
Knight f3 and for the purposes of this
particular Sicilian defense you can play
either c6 or d6 first and it's it's
likely to transpose the point of d6 is
you want to put your knight on f6
without having to worry about a 5 and
here white chooses to play an open
Sicilian so black should trade a side
pawn for a central pawn white gets a
little bit more space on the kingside
and after the moves Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 we have a very common position and
we've talked in the past about a6 the
knight orphe and we've talked about the
dragon but today we're going to talk
about a slightly what's that you
remember it was that a good one ok it
was a good one all right good
endorsed by Aaron Lynn so a good episode
we're going to get to movie six so this
is the shaven in-game pawn structure and
I won't even attempt to pronounce it
right because I have no chance but black
here he's just comfortable he's content
with having sort of a modest center that
controls quite a lot of squares along
the fifth rank so it's not something as
aggressive as he's going to try to play
an early e5 he's going to just slowly
get his pieces out and and wait for his
chances to have a counter-attack
you'll notice too what's in the Trump
for black here is he has this half open
C file so sometimes he can get some
pressure down the C file
whereas White has some pressure down the
D file so occasionally the d6 pawn ends
up being weak though that shouldn't
happen if black is careful and from here
we're going to look at a at three
different moves
and the main move that will come to last
is actually going to be the dreaded key
rays attack right very aggressive stuff
very early g4 this is the way that you
can try to exploit the fact that there's
already a pawn on e6 normally there
would be two pieces here that could take
this but now there's a pawn in the way
so that's one way to attempt to punish
this move order by black which is why I
often even in this position some people
intending to play the the same pawn
structure will start off with an AI Dorf
and they'll play the move a six and then
after white determines what he's going
to do you'll follow it up not with E 5
but with a six and you get the same sort
of pawn structure but you've eliminated
that option for white of playing the
curious attack we'll also look at the
English attack which is just Bishop to
e3 a very normal move but first we'll
check out the after e6 the classical
line which is Bishop to e2 so in this
variation white is just going to castle
develop his pieces and so both sides are
happy just to get their pieces out and
Castle and only then start thinking
about a middle game plan and for white
the middle game is going to usually
involve moves like f4 getting more space
he has yeah he has more space on the
kingside so that's where he should aim
to play often he'll follow that up with
f5 trying to attack some of the the
light squares over on the King side all
right we got the ringer in the house mr.
Perret cyl also on the agenda
even after f4 you can consider g4 g5
this is very common maneuver and the
Queen often goes to e1 and sometimes the
g3 and he's going to try to play moves
like f5 or a 5 and somehow break in the
center here black on the other hand is
going to be playing on the Queen side
and do a minority attack so his typical
moves include a6 and b5
this is why in the knight or if you
would already have started with a 6 so
it's definitely still on the agenda even
though here black is is delaying playing
a6 for as long as possible and if you
play this way then you'll probably end
up putting the knight
right over here and the bishop over here
and another common way is just to play
Knight to c6 and after a six you'll
exchange on d4 before playing b5 and
we'll get to see that okay so a typical
move here for white would be Bishop to
e3 and Knight to c6 all right so white
gets on with his idea and black gets on
with his okay so both sides in this
variation are just kind of doing what
they want and here white gets to make a
choice he can either try to stop black
from doing what he wants to do with a
move like a 4 which is actually the most
common move or he can think about just
getting on what he wants to do and
ignoring what Black's up to so in this
position we want to play b5 so what
commonly happens is we we don't want to
drop our Knight
so first we trade and after they take
back we get to play the move b5 and it's
it's very interesting playing these sort
of defenses because it's sort of white
doesn't really want to make any moves
over on the Queen side but you also want
to balance slowing down Black's attack -
he was probably getting ready to play an
early b4 so a3 makes some sense and
after a couple more moves it looks like
we're attacking e4 twice and white
actually has a pretty clever move here
Queen to g3 so there's there's a pin
here on the G file we got lots of
pressure on g7 so yeah don't don't take
this pawn that would be a slight a
slight mistake not a slight one
it's a checkmate oh boy alright good
thing Aaron Lind was here okay so
instead you know there's there's several
moves okay move like g6 is often played
okay now you're not getting checkmated
so now you are threatening the e pawn so
I have to move like this we'll go one
move farther down the line here not that
this is you know necessarily the best
move ever but it does illustrate sort of
one thing that you want to be looking
for in this opening which is sort of
pawn sacrifices these are going to be on
both sides yeah you want to think about
moves here like a 5 a clever little move
ok undefended the beep on but this night
is stuck defending e4 so if you take on
b5 we take on e4 and that's a pretty
good deal for black who got to trade his
beep on for Annie Pond so stuff like
this happens all the time so you're you
want to be looking for clever ways to
play on both sides and balance the
attack with the defense but we'll go
back a couple moves here and we'll see a
more common try instead of Queen to e1
more often white plays the move a4 just
you know restricting black from playing
b5 and we'll see now you have to do
something a little bit different the
Queen usually belongs on c7 in these
lines it's nice that you have c-file
pressure but sometimes black is thinking
about playing the move e5 it does have
to be well timed because you are giving
up the d5 square but if white ever plays
g4 you might want to hit them with a
quick 'if I've or you might want to
trade on d4 first and then hit them with
E 5 to create some structural weaknesses
on the King side for him and we'll see
that here in the main line ok now white
can continue with further prophylactic
moves such as King to h1 and he's also
waiting to see how black is going to set
up white will probably play Bishop to f3
then you'll play g4 and ok then he's
thinking about g5 in an attack ok and
there's a couple different moves here
the move that's favored by Kasparov and
has been the most popular is rook to e8
so he's thinking about eventually
getting some counter play on the e-file
after a move like a 5 he's going to put
the bishop on f8 and play e5 also
popular enough is Bishop to d7 followed
by this trade and bringing the bishop
over to c6
it's also possible just to play b6 and
get your Bishop on the diagonal where he
belongs
ok but we'll look at the the main and
most theoretical move because in this
class we're not afraid of a theoretical
challenge so we'll look at the
complicated okay now here it comes
notice where these are these rooks are
placed here this is very typical you
want to put them on ei 10 b8 it occurs
just a lot not only in the this line but
in several lines especially when they
played a four so the works on b8 so that
you can play b5 after you've exchanged
on d4 and you can safely play it okay so
now g4 and now what's that going for his
plan what's black going to play here
trade the night okay trading the night
makes some sense although here and you
can take back either way let's just
we'll just take it one way normally this
is a good idea when you're able to play
b5 but here you're still unable to play
b5 so it doesn't make quite as much
sense here black plays a really tricky
move this is why this is the the more
complicated theoretical move sorry if we
go back
aha after trading what was his next
moved you know b5 exactly alright so you
all are giving up control over d5 so you
got to be pretty careful cuz white might
play g5 and 95 after your Knight moves
like that could be pretty bad but it's
all well calculated now after the trade
void has to move his Bishop but what's
the most accurate Square for the bishop
you have a tricky little move here in
the trickiest and most accurate is a
move you don't see every day
Bishop to a7 so before going back to a
nice normal square like III you're
forcing the rook back to the a file so
that it's harder for black to play b5 in
the future so black goes back
and you might be expecting Bishop to e3
looks normal enough but a trickier move
is g5 now who wants the Machuca rook
I wish Danny were here so we can make
fun of them again for the Machuca rook
although in this case you know and
sicilians it's not always so bad to have
a rook on a seven occasionally you know
they'll swing over to d7 and that'll be
fine but uh you know whenever I get the
chance to mention the Machuca rook you
know you can't miss canvas a good
opportunity okay so what would you guys
do here so you don't really want to move
your knight you don't want the Machuca
rook you know if you move your knight
the Knight to d5 is coming so black
should insert the move rook to d8 all
right I'm attacking you you're attacking
me and then I attack another thing
that's the way to do it and after the
Queen moves your knight has to retreat
okay and since the bishop is under
attack
you have just enough time to be prepared
against the move Knight to d5 with the
move Bishop to e6 and so this is the
sort of the starting point for the the
main line here it's all it's all been
you know studied extensively for a long
time and white does have lots of
attacking chances but he is creating
lots of weaknesses over on the Kings
side so either he's going to
successfully go make the black King or
he's just going to end up with a much
worse position going into the endgame so
if black could trade a lot of pieces he
would have the the much better pawn
structure here and then he'd be looking
pretty good but that all have to do it
for our coverage here of the classical
okay we'll go back welcome everybody
alright now we've got a real party in
here this is good this is good
much better than last week all right
okay so here we go we return to the
position if you're if you're just coming
in this is the Sicilian shape and ingen
where black is very modest in the center
and okay now we're going to focus on a
different move the English attack which
is popular in all sorts of Sicilians and
here the nice bonus for white is
you never have to worry about the early
unite to g4 stuff harassing your bishop
because you put the e pawn in the way of
your bishop so you know the Queen would
just take it so that so you don't have
to worry about that variation and we're
going to see why it's set up a little
bit differently
white intends the very aggressive f3
Queen d2 followed by castling and then
g4 h4 and checkmate so this is a very
aggressive way to play and okay he still
has the option of going back to the
classical lines he still could follow up
with Bishop to e2 f4 and you could
castle on the Kings side and we get sort
of the same thing so you don't really
know exactly yet what he's up to as
Blackman we're going to wait to see what
his intentions are with his F pawn and
the main move if you want to keep it in
you know third of the strict stay
Finnegan territory would be to play
Bishop to e7 but I would like to
contrast this with the move a six which
now transposes to an i Dorf except you
haven't played the main move which would
be this position with the pawn on e5 so
you could reach the NIE Dorf here in
this position and then you could play
the movie six and you would reach this
position so this is also worth
mentioning because in my knight or video
we only covered here so here we get a
little bit more now the the main moves
are f3 and if b5 we're getting ready and
an accurate move now that the night is
on d7 and you could Castle what a nice
accurate move here is g4 the point is if
you get to play the move g5 this Knight
would really like the d7 square but
there's already somebody in the way so
there's two things you can one just get
this guy out of the way that seems you
know to make a lot of sense and then if
if g5 you can put the other night on d7
so they're they're both safe or you can
play the move h6
which is the more popular way to play
and with this move you are slowing down
you know White's counter play on the
King side for a bit but now it's going
to be much riskier in the future to
Castle kingside
so very often your king is going to
end up in the center because white will
in the future be able to play moves like
h4 g5 or h4 h5 and only then g5 so he
will have some way of opening some files
over there on the kingside so your King
might end up in the center these things
happen okay so after castles and Bishop
e7 h4 things are getting pretty serious
black now can play b4 and it's it's time
to figure out what you're going to do
with with the knight who's he to more
commonly he goes to a4 do you see that
one coming it's a bad move
it's the most popular move in a highly
theoretical opening discuss it's a bad
move why is it a bad move all right look
yeah nice on the side not very good mmm
so yeah Knights on the side look at this
you know you're gonna be really scared
now he's attacking your knight right
Oh knight on the side yeah maybe it's
not looking very good is it not very
scary yeah what are you gonna do about
your night you only have one move
b3 okay okay b3 excellent not a move you
want to make with white obviously you're
creating quite a lot of weaknesses
around your King over there and it does
seem like white might be getting into a
little bit of trouble if you've never
seen this before because if your knight
ever moves I'm on your a2 pond and here
black can attack the knight again Knight
to c5 and now it's looking bad right if
I play Knight takes a4 and I'm really
going to ruin your King side so you got
to be really careful here also if you
take my knight I'll just take back on c5
and then I'll be able to take on a2 and
you can also be in trouble so we'll see
if anyone in here knows this defensive
resource it's not a very common one but
it is quite a cool one to know so if
you've never seen White's next move
prepare to be amazed let's see does
anybody see it alright wait to move and
not lose so this is quite a clever idea
the move is a three so obviously there's
a pin here so this would be a big
mistake
you wouldn't yeah so okay so we take the
knight and that white takes back on
before so our Queen must retreat and
then white gets to take the knight and
sort of an extraordinary thing that
doesn't usually happen in this pawn
structure normally you think of black
doing the minority attack and you you
don't often think the white will be able
to push his big majority over here but
in these positions the majority actually
does seem to matter for white who will
often follow up with moves like c4 in
the future and he will try to use his
past funds to get a lot of counter play
so obviously if you ever play a move
like a five it'll be met with b5 so a
follow up might be d5 now II five
blundering upon
and now the queen is trapped okay so
yeah you don't take the pawn Knight to
d7 and after a move like f4 White will
be thinking about you know attacking in
the future Shh okay
and you also be thinking about using his
majority and he still has this one pawn
he hasn't moved yet
so when is he going to move it that's
how you play you know the Sicilian you
move all of your pawns and hope for the
best
all right you guys keep your pawns backs
where they're safe you got to go for it
that's how the Sicilian works okay and
so we'll go back so that's that's what
happens in the night or F move order so
we'll return to this position and now
instead of the move a six we'll examine
the move Bishop to e7 okay and we'll get
a very similar position where after we
castle we will at some point have to
play the moves a six and b5 which means
in this variation before we play b5 we
need to remember to trade the knight and
now it's always interesting in this
position what you want to take back with
because both moves make some sense and
they've both been played so you can take
the night with a bishop or the Queen and
it does tend to matter on the exact
concrete position in front of you to
determine which way you do want to take
but we'll just we'll just show you the
main way the bishop okay taking with the
Queen also makes some sense because
you're just keeping the heavy pieces on
the D file but will understand why the
bishop is here in just a minute okay
now after b5 we'll get a very similar
scenario where the knight comes out and
we get to play here and after b3 again
we'll play Knight to c5 but now we see
why white took with the bishop because
now he also has the possible move Bishop
takes c5 which is why a six is probably
a slightly more accurate way for for
black to play knowing that this is the
way the position might lead and also
what has a very very interesting move
that okay you probably wouldn't consider
unless you think about the fact that the
black Queen doesn't have a
a lot of squares to which she can go
right now the only you know safe squared
let's say we move the Queen that would
take the d8 square away the only square
the black queen can go to is c7 so why
it has a very interesting move here
Queen to f4 so it's funny your queen is
in a really good square but she's kind
of trapped there so in this position yes
she has has nowhere to go instead play
might continue okay we'll just we'll
show it I mean this is the move we want
to play we want to play like Bishop d7
but obviously that just drops a bishop
so instead look a seven so we will see
that maneuver we talked about and the
rook is headed over to d7 and so here
right we're going to try to now we can
safely move our Queen to if we ever have
to but we might double on the D file and
we're never going to mind you taking
because then I get to take back with my
bishop and attack your knight so okay so
that's sort of the main line here of the
English attack so we'll all the way back
to our starting position here and now
we'll look at the most aggressive move
in a move that has made many players
stop playing this variation including
Kasparov who would later use like the
knight or move order just to avoid the
carries attack and so that that fearful
move here is the move g4 so a very
aggressive way to play obviously we're
just we're just playing g5 right away
we've seen in most lines you know we're
just going to go like this in Castle
queenside but we're going to get the
attack going right away right from the
start and it's it's well advised the
black just slows down the attack with
the move h6 and there are some ways to
just allow him to play the move g5
for example equally Bishop e7 a6
the most popular way is to play Knight
to c6 will return to the move h6 in just
a minute here but this does allow the
move g5 and so now you must go back and
White has a nice flexible move here
Bishop to e3 he's one step closer to
castling queenside and he is reserving
an option here that we'll look at in
just a minute and so this is going to be
a lot like the English attack only the
fact that we've already gotten g5 in and
we can play h4 immediately it's like an
English attack on steroids
so some people like to avoid the steroid
attack all right Bishop to e7 attacking
the pawn and we'll we'll come back to
the obvious way of defending it which is
h4 but I do want to point out one
attacking plan that white has - which
blacks should know a certain defensive
resource also possible is rook to g1 the
point is the very crude Queen to h5
followed by maneuvering the rook to h3
and if you're castled we meet you on h7
all right so this is part of the the
plan so this is why white hasn't played
h4 just yet but okay if we Castle Queen
h5 and put a couple more moves here on
the board and now black needs to start
thinking about defense and how he's
going to defend against this maneuver so
we'll test your defensive skills so that
the main way to deal with this threat is
rook to e8 the point is even if you put
a rook here what move can we play to
defend h7 Knight f8 right so this is
sort of like the old adage Knight on FA
can't be made so so that that'll help
defend the at the H pawn so this is a
good defensive maneuver to keep in mind
okay so play might continue with this
and now okay if you play H work h3 at
any point then I'll play 9 f8 so also I
can trade play b5 and we'll get a
position like this where okay things are
still quite dangerous for black white
isn't ending you know just to go get you
and his attack should probably land a
little bit faster than it would in a
normal English attack and we'll go back
now and we'll look at one more move in
this
this here before we go back to the main
line okay white also might play the move
h4 yeah okay so after castling it makes
sense okay so here's the main line in
this variation so again we're going to
give a position like this and again it's
which it's a decision you have to make
here taking what the Queen makes a lot
of sense you're keeping the the D file
clear so you'll always have pressure on
the d6 pawn and there's some other small
benefits of taking with the Queen one is
now the knight can't go to b6 because
it's attacked twice and if ever you play
B 5 B 4 well I might be able to just
take your beep on so you would have to
perhaps prepare it with rook to b8 and
then b5 before so okay but mostly we
have the pressure on the D file and all
right now we can continue and this also
would be a another way to play but
White's attack obviously is quite fast
as pawns are quite advanced and f4 f5
has come in fairly quickly here so okay
which is why if we go all the way back
to the beginning of the carries attack
this is our starting position here we
see the main move just preventing for
the moment at least the move g5 so now
you can play g5 it's it's been played by
good people but black shouldn't have any
serious problems after taking notice now
that the pawn on h2 is much weaker so
white is taking on sort of a weakened
pawn structure and black shouldn't have
too many worries here so he can develop
there's there's no reason not just to
make a normal move and if we go a few
moves down the line this also is an
important maneuver to keep in mind so
this will recur in a lot of themes and
in then the 9 or f2 this also is a
popular theme the idea of Queen to b6
which is not the best square for the
Queen because you're going to play a 6
and b5 so now you're in the way but the
idea is to force the knight on d4 to a
worse square since white has the worst
pawn structure he doesn't want to go
into the endgame his H pawn is weak
black has more central pawns than wipe
so we are just threatening to trade a
lot of pieces
which would be two blacks advantage and
so only after moving the night now at
some point we can put the Queen back on
c7 which is what we're really attending
okay we can play a couple moves first
and after castling we can play Bishop d7
or the immediate Queen to c7 and then
we'll be able to play b5 next so that's
an important maneuver just to keep in
mind so I just wanted to showcase that
idea so g5 not the most common move here
the most common move is to not joke
around we're really serious h4 so due to
the pin on the H file g5 is again not a
huge threat so we don't need to worry
about it just yet we can make a normal
move and now if g5 we again can take and
we'll get this the same variation
obviously we can't take with a pawn
because the paint on ya the rook okay so
instead here so we get the same position
only White's played h4 and blacks played
Knight to c6 which is probably two
blacks advantage but what move here
would black play we'll see if the
audience is paying attention this should
be seven is a fine move yeah there's
nothing wrong with that but that's a but
something a little more accurate Queen
b6 excellent
so again yeah we want to trade lots of
pieces so after he goes back I will get
a similar position like this and stop
the stop trading all your pieces okay so
after h4 96 the most common move here is
rook to g1 okay now g5 is is definitely
coming and black has a move here that
okay you might not find at you know to
see your first time seeing this position
but a very clever move
h5 so we're seeing a lot of moves on the
King side and now perhaps the move that
most people would just play naturally is
not the most popular move the main move
is to take on h5 which compromises your
pawn structure but you get a lot of play
down the G file so we'll look
at that in our main game today but I
think a lot of people facing this for
the first time would play the move g5
right seems like a seems like a good
move attack the knight maybe you'll have
to go back to d7 but we see sort of the
point of the move h5 now the knight can
hop into g4 and we're not getting
trapped because notice if you play f3 we
have the e5 square but also if you just
play the move f3 which is not the most
common move black actually has a
tactical move up here so we'll see if
somebody can spot it so you could move
the knight back to e5 that's that's
perfectly alright but you also have a
different move you see it h2 9h - you're
going to jump in here
are you ever going to get out what if
what if I move this guy are you ever
getting out of there
what if I do this in this mmm so you're
not the safest yeah you don't want to go
too far into their territory but you
actually don't have to move it you have
a tactical move here yeah okay excellent
okay we got it
we got the answer here Queen b6
excellent so notice there's a pin here
so the knight can't really move so if
your knight takes then we take your rook
okay excellent
umm yes okay we got to get we got to get
through here we're going to go a little
bit faster okay but AB Bishop e2 not the
only move but uh okay this let's look at
this I think that's what a lot of people
would instinctively play okay we're just
we're going to take on g4 and black
actually has several ways to a2 gambit
upon you could obviously play Knight to
e5 that's fine but moves like g6 are
even possible and even the move Queen to
b6 so we're noticing a trend on where
that black Queen likes to go in this
variation and so here even if white
takes which okay at this point you
probably should and we take back we can
do some trades white can take back he's
won upon but very few humans go in for
this variation because after the move g6
black has a lot of activity this guy is
quite weak he needs some babysitting we
got lots of pressure on the B file Shh
we're going to get lots of pressure down
this diagonal and with so many lines
very few people want to play this as
white the way that this is commonly
played is a sort of a surprising move
not the move you want to play b3 and
then after such moves we can attack the
knight again you can defend your knight
and what's funny too is the computer
thinks white is a little bit better it's
like are you're up upon but very few
humans are willing to play this way I
think it's a lot easier to play black
and I was surprised that it thought you
know that out the white was better and I
think it's much easier to play black
here you know but you know if your
computer and you're like being up upon
this this might be the variation for you
okay okay so we return here to the main
move and if only Danny would shook over
here we could we had a discussion about
this position and which way you should
take on h5 and it was his suggestion
that you take with the rook which is not
common but it has been played and after
this move white plays Bishop to g5 with
the big threat so B gotta pay attention
here we're going to take on f6 and once
you recapture the rook is going to be
hanging so you have to you know move
your rook back so notice this position
and now we'll compare it to a position
where you take first with the knight now
Bishop to g5 and the main move is Knight
to f6 so you get the same exact position
only if you take with your knight first
I was arguing this is more accurate
because black can still Castle in this
position you can still Castle kingside
in the future and Danny made the point
yeah but obviously you're not going to
Castle kingside in this variation which
is probably true but I argue it's more
accurate to take with the night because
who knows I mean in some endgame [ __ ]
Castle kingside
but okay so this it is very unlikely but
is it the most accurate discuss fight
okay
and in this position we'll stop it will
we'll get to our main featured game here
okay so this is the game between an IM
rated 2419 vs. luke fun Whaley with the
black pieces here so okay he he's a well
known for playing this variation and in
this line he started with the movie six
we mentioned that you could you could
also start this way we get an open
Sicilian Knight f6 so nice III is coming
we will mention the 1/1 basic tactical
trick I mean what if we just play e5
right away yeah Queen a5 check and then
you pick up the pawn so this would this
would blender upon which is why yeah
okay so you can play d5 Knight to c3 now
you are thinking about playing a5
because there's no more check okay so d6
was played and we got the Curie's attack
are there any children that can tell me
what white played here are mostly
looking at you what could it be what
could it be
g5 OG 4 okay excellent
okay indeed black let white push them
all around or did he play h6 what do you
think
did he play the move this on the board
or a different move
okay the movies on the board okay and
what was serious
h4 okay it's we're not threatening g5
just yet but after rook g1 at what move
do we play here resigns it's it's a bit
excessive it's a bit excessive we na v
some some legal move alright g5 is still
coming here okay
h5 excellent okay and white took black
took back with the night and okay so now
we're back to this position
and now we can see what happened in this
game okay white played the main move
Queen d2 he's going to Castle queenside
very logical and I'm really did not play
the most common move here what do you
guys think the most common move is ya
Queen b6 so
this is you know the typical way to play
it again we're trying to force the night
back and so on this line it does make
sense to keep the Queen on b6 just a
little bit longer because there's a pin
here so if you have a move you're up on
I take your rook so you can actually
delay it for one more move but after
white gets out of the pin probably Queen
c7 and you're thinking okay you can
Castle queenside in a lot of lines and
you can play b5 early if you want to go
on the attack so this is the main way to
play but uh he also showed that you can
you know let white keep his knight here
in the center and still play a move such
as a six so this is the move it was was
played in the game okay white castled
Bishop d7 okay just normal developing
move maybe we'll get to take on d4 and
play Bishop c6 that's one way to get
onto that that long diagonal also we
might just be thinking about playing a
move like b5 but now here comes f4 and
white intends the move f5 getting lots
and lots of pressure on e6 he can also
in the future use his bishop to also
attack a six so he's definitely going to
attack the light squares okay now we see
Queen to b6 notice that this would be a
very bad blunder because your work on g1
is hanging so he didn't play there but
he doesn't want to trade the knight you
know really good for black would be if
we got to take on d4 and maybe we even
traded the Queen so would that be great
so what moved in white play here to not
trade and to protect his rook on g1 it's
a tall order
moving the f1 bishop how are you going
to avoid this trade by moving your
bishop and and not blender your rope
Queen III okay which okay then I guess
okay I get to trade one piece at least
okay so this is not it
ninety-two okay okay which I assume is
possible to there's this more than one
answer here that's good okay but he went
to if3 alrighty
yes yeah and then he can get his Bishop
out to he's on the way
yeah it's a pretty good square and so
castling here would just be fine that's
a normal move you know I think I think
castling would just be move we would
just almost play on instinct here the
black played for a little bit more he
played Knight 2h7
so he's going for the bishop pair he's
going to take the bishop on g5 it's
hanging it's not quite hanging because
there are there are a few things that
are defending it okay
and we would also be thinking about
playing move like f6 trapping the bishop
and white wanted to play the move quiet
please
f5 this was on his agenda anyway so okay
that's what he played and this was
blacks idea to take the bishop and now
there's four ways to take the knight
back and three of them make some sense
Knight take doesn't make sense because
your rook is still hanging on g1 but
other moves make a lot of sense in the
game he played the most positional he
took back reunited his pawns and he's
thinking in the future of playing a move
like g6 really undermining the light
squares but also interesting is a move
like Queen to g5 so this you know is
preferring the piece activity over the
pawn structure and I was thinking to
myself when I first saw this something
okay I got to put this on the engine see
what black should play here because it
seems like an irritating move now you
can't Castle queenside and you gotta
gotta play a move here and nobody would
play like a computer here so would have
been interesting to see how a human
would have reacted to this but there's a
there's a maneuver you may want to pause
your video we're gonna four time we're
just going to give it away something
tells me the audience might not be able
to find this
something tells me okay there's a
maneuver rook h6 to f6 now we can castle
yeah so I don't know if I Whaley would
have found that I don't know who knows
maybe he would have thought that and
yeah okay there's all sorts of crazy
stuff but Afghan for time well we'll go
back to that the more human way to play
this which is okay you connect your
pawns you're thinking about playing g6
so black could think about castling but
to prevent g6 he played g6 himself
all right now he took creating weakness
on g6 in that white is going to try to
attack it he's thinking about putting a
bishop here because that would sometimes
attack that pawn so he played a move he
played a5 which is you know sort of a
risky move this pawn has a pretty good
purpose here it is is a very good pun
but he moved it there is a pan on the D
file so if you take here Queen takes d7
and checkmate yeah so it's this is a
little bit bad for black it was really
bad okay I apologize okay so so d5 was
played now we're going to play moves
like Bishop to d3 with pressure on g6
and we have some sacrificial ideas
looming in the position so and yet Dani
Machuca said he's not coming to this
lecture because i used the word looming
to describe this threat he's like
looming I'm not coming true story okay
so you okay you could so how are you
going to defend your pawn you can
consider sacking it just castling that
keeps your pieces in good positions but
okay he's a grandmaster and he likes his
pawns so he played rook to g8 I move so
simple even the kids in the audience
could see it so route to g8 was played
and now a very interesting move Knight
to h4 unoffending the e pawn so is it is
it a poisoned pawn can you take on e5 if
that's the big question because in the
game he took it so I think there's a mop
in the back
okay and now I white played a shocking
move then we're gonna have to go way way
in the back of the room to try to figure
out what white played in this position
awesome yeah excellent so he did take on
d5 perfectly said okay so he took and he
pinned the piece okay so he's just
looking to get the piece back and in the
game black just castled not defending
the piece it's going to be dead but okay
how are you going to do it prove it what
if I play Bishop to d6 this wasn't
played is playing anything takes g6 so
for example Bishop takes check excellent
in this position you can pause your
videos at home but for time the move
here Queen takes d5 attacking the rook
and making another threat
rook takes e5 and okay here black is in
a bad way also after this move we can
take with the night also this is
interesting and okay so you can you
could just Castle here leaving your
night on pre but you get to safety if
you try too hard to take it both
captures on e5 work the more interesting
one is to take with the rook and after
you capture back you can take back with
the night because you can't play Queen
takes e5 due to rook e1 so okay then you
just have to Castle and why it would be
better in an endgame if we just traded
played g6 and even though it's only one
pond for the exchange this pond is a
monster and this I'd rather have this
pond then in exchange alright let's
let's let's go back to the game here
sorry okay so in this position Plex
decides play the safest move just castle
give it back and after you take back key
five is not the optimal square for a
rook exactly okay if you get to take on
d5 then you're thin you're happy but
what move did black play here mister g7
looks good I agree so yeah so now
there's a there's a pin on the rook
notice the b2 pond so moving would be be
pretty bad
slightly worse or zerrin would say no
that's really worse yeah don't move your
hook okay
so said he got to take the pawn okay now
you could take a pinch piece but he's a
grandmaster so he attacked a pinned
piece okay so white one here and it's
it's also kind of an interesting
position you can take either way they
both kind of make sense your bishop is
really good so playing rook takes rook
makes some sense but okay he decided to
take the exchange also good and after
this move but found a really accurate
move and after this move white started
to go wrong and it's okay so move it
maybe maybe some people would consider
but it's it's not the easiest to see
he played the move Queen to d4 attacking
the knight and then white played what
seems like the normal move he just took
the bishop this actually is a inaccurate
and he starts starts to go wrong after
this move you should think about playing
a move like c3 just kicking the Queen
away and then he doesn't have to move
his knight but in the game he took on d7
so we'll just we'll just focus on the
game
should we take like this and hang the
rook on the 8th okay he didn't do that
so he took white took back with what
with the rook well he took with his king
now if you take with the rook you are
sometimes running into this move when it
doesn't work right away but okay he
didn't want to line his pieces up on
light squares his opponent has a light
squared bishop so he wants to keep his
rook on a dark square seems to make
sense and the safest square for the King
is probably a 7 so he'll in some way run
over there he has two ways to go over
there so that's where he's going to end
up where he's nice and safe and ok white
could just make a simple move here like
g6 that would seem to make make some
sense I guess he's kind of worried about
his back rank because if there's ever a
rook that somehow you know gets back
here some bad stuff is gonna happen ok
so in the game he checked the King ran
away and white okay should somehow make
some lift the problem for him too is g6
is now meant by Queen to f4 which picks
up the bishop okay so he checked we
blocked and man this he's an IM so he
sees a lot of checks but he is running
away from his back rank which gets him
into some trouble okay
and now the problem for them here is
that the best move is b3 just making
some lift and then somehow you don't get
checkmated but it's it's not a very
human response because then it's like
okay I just play Queen a4 check and I
take this pawn and this is an important
pun to you if this pawn is on a safe
square like g6 then you're doing very
well but okay if white plays b3 maybe
it'll I mean he's going to be worse but
maybe he can hold it together but after
this move now he is in serious trouble
now there's lots of moves that win but
he played the best and the most accurate
so uh okay I will would challenge the
audience okay it's a lot of moves win
here what's the most accurate and most
precise move yeah Rick c6 is tempting
and it's a decent move the strongest
move is rook f6 and now I went crazy b4
okay um okay we'll look at that okay
that I mean sort of the point is if you
could do this which is actually a good
move then you can go somewhere and then
we can check make you that would be
embarrassing okay but this this looks
bad and it is really bad perhaps the
most testing was Bishop to d3 you know
it seems like the most obvious try and
hopefully you're you at home for time
we're just going to show the the answer
here even though it's incredibly
complicated you check if you don't want
to get check mated immediately you go to
d1 and here I was when I would looked at
this before we looked at it with an
engine I was doing it with a dani
Huachuca we're looking at the move rook
to f2 which is a winning move though
it's actually really complicated then
we'll show that the move that wins a
little bit faster and after here you
know all right you can check and then
the problem is there's only one move
that wins here for black and it might be
hard to find so you can try to find it
at home it's a the only move that wins
for black is Queen to f4 a hard move to
find but white is threatening a
perpetual with Queen to d4 alright we
won't we won't discuss how it's a
perpetual but uh you have to you have to
take my word for it or you can think
about it for yourself
so yeah you'd have to play here and then
okay you're gonna you're going to
checkmate them soon probably you know
there's more than one way but sometimes
you have to get this guy over here is
it's sort of poured on the point okay
and also another complicated way after
this after this move is okay we check
alright so the computer move is also
really hard to find rook to e6 whoa that
threatens checkmate so you have to
somehow not get checkmated so you can
check and then your queen can come over
defending the e1 square and okay trying
to figure out how to win here in the
most precise way also very difficult so
if anyone can play the computer move
here I'll give you a free DVD you know
it okay you get one guess
Queen Ji Won not the best move nope
anyone else not clean f3 nope so the
computer moved here
rope to e5 the idea is to do this and
that's hard to stop a very you know a
very complicated idea so it would have
been interesting had he played a little
bit more like a human in this position
with you know Bishop to d3 how would one
really have you know really finished him
off what do you found all this but he
went crazy he played before and now
black played the safest move it's it's
not the computer best but okay he's like
I'll just I'll just go back we won't
show the computer line because it's it's
ridiculous and even more complicated
than everything else but okay you're
still totally winning after this it
doesn't change very much
he brought his bishop back now fine I'll
take it fine and now again not the most
precise move after this now you're just
you're losing very quickly obviously you
have to play King d1 goes without saying
LCA and then you like very difficult but
you still be mated okay but after this
this is a position in which even the
audience could mate an i M so this is a
slightly simpler task so this will be
the very last puzzle a couple more moves
are played here Queen Queen e1 rook b6
and then here he resigned
okay so we're almost done here people
okay now I have a challenge for
everybody who can last two moves as
white I think a lot of people see see
I'm eight and one but who can survive
for two moves can you do it I bet you
could do it how do you do it
excellent surviving for one more move
good move the best move okay and then
we'll ask all around in the front row
what's the move here excellent
all right good job today you got one
right very good okay so this was the end
of the game so this is sort of an intro
to the shape and ingen hopefully you
guys have enjoyed it
it was a pretty fun class here tonight a
little rambunctious but uh there's a lot
of people so it was a little fun so
please keep sending in the videos that
you guys want to see hit like subscribe
share and starting tomorrow we'll have
the very first ever strategy session
with Jonathan trance I don't know who
will be teaching that class so stay
tuned we'll find out tomorrow